what is happening there reject nation
greg and john here today we're gonna
watch the witcher episode two of season
one as we're slowly playing catch up
here before season two comes out doing
our best to be on top of it guys i asked
that you could please go ahead and hit
that like button um hit that like button
please really helps time the algorithm
also subscribe click that notification
bell get notified when our reaction for
the next witcher episode is up
we're gonna watch this with subtitles
today to make our life a little bit
easier to keep up with such an intricate
show appreciate your understanding if it
really bothers you let us know but if
not enough people are bothered we're
going to continue doing it this way full
length watch launch we stick up with the
top code or our patreon page for the
witcher cover a bunch of shows over
there we're at the same tier you get the
option for both reaction highlights and
watch alongs included lastly thank you
to the boys at prepper for helping us
edit down these highlights let's get
into action people
a daisy
not a rose roses are cliche daisies are
cheap i can still
kiss you right
she ain't that mad where did it go my
daisy
why you didn't want it
now someone else has it so i do want it
hunchback
your father makes you sleepy
[Music]
people were so mean back then back then
1953
[Laughter]
oh you're a virgin
that's the first thing he notices
if you could conjure that portal out of
thin air she'll be coming for you
what are you doing
you gotta hulk out or die it's a
different kind of portal one that can't
be tracked
see the one you made has put a target on
your back
but this will take you home
look you can trust me
we just met
the chickens are behind this
not much for this beast
six four so
four marks
[ __ ]
sold
four marks actually take her for three
she's our daughter she's no daughter of
mine please help me
excellent i'll be going
don't trust melisandre
damn this one was breaking my [ __ ]
heart man
[ __ ]
that mirror sucked anyway
oh
[Music]
oh she's dutching herself
that's a predator reference yes
why are your parents
why don't we talk
excellent questions
[Music]
[Applause]
it's like i have a 40s jazz lounge or
something yeah
was abortion even a word in whatever
time this is modeled after sure
hey devil
he's been stealing all our grain in
advance we'll pay you
100
150.
i've got two one for each of the uh
devil's horns oh my god he's got a funny
companion yeah
[Music]
how much money did the show cost
seriously
we could do game of thrones too
who are you
to say a devries
rector savaratuza
oh
lift your stone without touching it
use the incantation zelen ape
she's got the magic i'm doing it your
hands
golly oh my no
there is no conjuring something from
nothing
there is a give and a take rules of
alchemy law of equivalent exchange
how fascinating
ape
level is
come on i'm so rooting for you so much
no idea how my heart feels first
right now
so good
sometimes a flower is just a flower
and the best thing it can do for us is
to die
goddamn why is everyone so [ __ ]
meaner i know
oh yeah one person is
destroying me right now
your shoes
let's get you a fresh bear why don't we
thank you
abbott
give her your shoes
don't worry he's one of the clean ones
oh he is giving his shoes oh
hello
what are we looking for again blessed
silence
my
man i have to see this magical this
mythical
i'm pretty sure it's just a person with
a mask right it's mephisto sounds like
they're just uh slingshotting it yes
yeah
[Music]
i got from humans who left out food
filled with iron not to poison me
did your mother [ __ ] a snowman
you are intelligent i'll give you that
she did
but you can't stay here
neither can you
[Music]
whoa yeah that was awesome
you can read me
if you like
just look past
you're craving a hot dog
you want to get out of this cave
moon jellyfish
these are the things i thought you would
love
i like that guy
is a charmer we get through this
together
we take care of our own
that woman's going to die
her old family's probably going to die
this trial tests your ability to control
the ultimate expression of chaos catch
it in a bottle catch
lightning in a bottle cool
i did
it oh god
oh no
sabrina
show these girls how it's done
oh
maybe you're a little bit absorb the
lighting or something that's absolutely
how it looks
the strong
amongst the weak
[Music]
what were you saying about strong
amongst the weak
the witcher could have killed me but he
didn't
he's different like us
if you must kill me i am ready but the
sylvan's right
don't call me human
whoa badass
i really
really enjoyed this episode a lot
[Laughter]
you see when humans and monsters all
arrived after the conjunction of the
spheres elven mages told the first
humans how to turn chaos into magic
and then
the humans slaughtered them sounds like
humans mm-hmm i think a potential power
would always belong to them sounds like
humans
yep
am i for real father he was half elf
he's blindness
why i'm cursed with twisted sign
why am only worth four marks
[Music]
simply wanted to know that you could
control your emotions and get it from
the boy
that you would
you may go jennifer
oh my god
i'm ready
listen for the knock
she just use him i i feel like it's
probably somewhere in the middle
you must be able to give me something
say what
make bernhardt proud
no
she's part off
what the hell no
come on stupid little [ __ ] pick it up
and go
no way wow
[Music]
come forth jennifer
[Music]
what do they turn into eels
you turn my friend into a slug or slug
eel oh
man star tender meat and so cried the
witcher
he can't be bleed that's not how it
happened where's your newfound respect
respect doesn't make history maybe it
should
little smiles exchange
cool
cool all right yeah i was uh i was
really into that i found i personally
found this episode to be
quite
transcendent
i was emotionally hooked into it from
beginning to end
and it is interesting i i don't know
what the production is like with witcher
if they
had a pilot and then they shot it then
it got picked up or if it was like a
straight to series type of order i'd
imagine with witcher it would be more of
a straight to series
but there were such differences with the
way this episode in particular was
executed and some of the aesthetic looks
especially with geralt that seemed to
look a tad different
to me and maybe it's the fact that he
was like captured a lot and more of like
the the daylight deserts looking types
of land a lot of desert but you know
more the outdoor bright and shiny kind
of exterior shots that he just looked
different
and so i i don't know what it was like
but it felt
like it had the impression and i could
be way wrong about this one of those
things where it's like a pilot was shot
got picked up and then the rest of the
episodes we're seeing are what they shot
back to back
no idea what the case is to be honest
um but you could feel like a different
grip on
the way the episode was executed this
time around and i would really enjoyed
like just the overall tone and the
atmosphere and i thought it in a very
fluid manner
managed to hop between the three
different story lines one with yennefer
siri
and geralt and i thought each were very
very interesting especially with how
they were introducing this world and
realm of elves and the different
perspectives like you had that one guy
who wanted to be a knight who was he
talking about phillip andreal for the
lamb drill when he was saying that
they're
the elves that once attacked them and
then so when their brother died he's
that's when he started like collecting
the ears of them because he's saying it
was from them who attacked them i think
so yeah
so it's like you're learning all about
the world of magics
specifically in this one it's like you
got the wizard introduced in the last
episode now we're really getting where
the magic comes from and this role of
chaos and how elves are the first one to
be imbued with it and i like the
deconstruction how you're kind of
peeling the layers backwards that the
elves are not really bad that they were
the ones who were truthfully scorned and
oppressed and the truth was kept away
you know because they were the
originators of all this
and i yeah i thought it was i thought it
was great i i i really i really loved
this episode a lot in the introduced
introduction of yennefer in particular
it's brought such great
such great nuance such great depth and
what a physically demanding role that is
to
uh to to bring here and i was i was i
was quite impressed with this one and uh
consider me considering officially
hooked by the heart now too yeah
yeah
yeah absolutely i thought i really liked
i'm interested by the way that they are
working in a sort of anthology aspect
but also you know following geralt and
following siri
and the way in which from at least you
know the first episode to this episode
you're getting these
these interesting expansions on the
world around you that don't necessarily
feel like they have to be linear but
they all feel connected
and of a greater whole and yeah i mean
this was cool because this episode
brought in
two new characters
at least two kind of
what feel like could be central
characters or recurring characters in
both yennefer and and jessica or jessica
uh you know both of them two very
different characters you know one is uh
much more sort of uh you know flamboyant
and fun and the other is very tortured
but i thought they both did a great job
and yeah jennifer like that actress just
had so much uh presence and so much
going on just behind her eyes and in her
face and in her body language and her
mannerisms and i mean the amount of
empathy i imagine you have to have to
really throw yourself into that
character and to really sort of imagine
up you know a heightened version of you
know a real conflict somebody might go
through i thought was really well lived
in and two i mean you know the way
they're establishing this world it's
like okay they're making comments on
colonization and all that and how you
know
history isn't always respectful and
certainly you know they'll spin it one
way like oh you know the elves
bequeathed us this land when really we
actually kind of came in took it
appropriated their magic mixed our own
[ __ ] in with it
you know and you see the ugliness and
the perspectives too because you know
it's interesting when you cut back to
the family that takes siri in
and they are
you know uh
preparing for their rise back to power
you know they're waiting for their
moment to you know reclaim whatever lost
glory they have and they're portrayed in
a somewhat sympathetic light because of
being in siri's perspective and watching
as you know she's yeah taken in and
nurtured by these humans but who also
have these uh nastier inclinations when
it comes to the elves and i like the
little uh
too just the thread of of that dark
character i think was his name uh who
you know is like following her and
helping her and it's not revealed until
way after all the other
context about elves what his true nature
is and the fact that you know he is
choosing to help despite you know this
clear wedge that exists between humans
and elves and you know you also got the
uh i
can't remember off the top of my head
what his
creature name was but you know the the
goat guy you know it's cool the way that
they're expanding out with
mythological things but also having
geralt be like you know half the stuff
you're singing about isn't real you know
so drawing that line of fantasy and
showing you where this world's use of
you know classic fantastical imagery and
creatures and tropes and whatnot comes
into play well the use of the song too
i like that guy a lot i thought it was
really fun yeah and he definitely has
like a
feeder presence about him
the entire time and like especially the
way his vocals are yeah it sounds a lot
like a dude who comes from theater and
is well trained
uh but him
rewriting history like having that be
the note to end on with geralt
of your you've learned that a lot of
history has been rewritten already
um just to the way the stories have been
passed on like with everything you've
been talking about
and then to have it even happen right
there as geralt's witnessing it with the
song coming into formation that this
moment in history is now being rewritten
yeah that it's not
sculpted through a bias yeah yeah and i
thought that was like a really great
personal touch for it and i liked uh
i liked henry cavill a lot in this
episode i i thought his
it's weird because the last episode said
like witchers or don't have emotion or
some [ __ ] like that and i'm like this
guy seems super emotional in this
episode
he seems angry he seems really really
enraged and probably distraught from the
experiences in the last in the prior
episode but especially coming in into
this one like that speech that he has
when he is tied up
uh
that was like some of the best acting
i've ever seen henry cavill do ever
and i really really bought it felt
felt that like kind of motivational rage
and everything he was just saying just
seemed so believable there were things
about
the way it was
there's a specific way to capture makeup
that it really felt like
in certain shots though
that it did look a bit like he was in a
wig and that he had contact lenses on
yeah got corn syrup on his face yeah
there were parts about like it was so
brightly lit
that some some of those moments started
to look like
i'm aware this is makeup yeah well it
made me wonder about the choice because
i don't think the actress who plays
jennifer actually has purple eyes and
clear it seems pretty clear that they
color corrected them and maybe it's just
because maybe she's got light eyes and
maybe you can do that but it did make me
curious as to like why
choose that effect for one character
that looks much more natural and then
choose you know pretty obvious context
for other characters well i don't i
don't think it comes down to that i
think it comes down to the way the
lighting was if it was actually done
though it because it's a big part that
people don't realize with makeup you
know if talking what makeup effects are
actually having this conversation with a
makeup effects artist last night is a
lot of times great like i didn't notice
anything bad about the makeup with henry
cavill in the first episode and nothing
drew my eye into being distracting
and
in this one though it was
there were times where it pulled me out
and i was like yeah that's the way this
episode this particular scene is being
lit because there are times where henry
cavill looks really good and there are
times where on the close-ups i'm like
this looks like makeup
yeah
but with her she was like jennifer was
constantly like the way they chose to
light her especially the times that her
purple eyes were brought out that was it
wasn't just like didn't feel like
natural lighting was surrounding them
true
really particularly keyed and shadowed i
was curious as to why they aren't
contacts when they clearly chose that
for so many other characters oh you guys
know why jennifer's wearing colors yeah
why she got color corrected just
eyes you know
i don't know it could be a combination
of both she could have contacts on and
then they
amp it up with the vfx
i think that's what they did with the
goat guy right
probably
they might have given him even some kind
of scleral like fly thing because he had
the different looking pupils and all
that well i'm saying he looked like he
was practical effect that they amped up
with some cgi in there yeah it makes
sense but i like like his performance
too like i like when you you get a
character and you immediately feel the
life of and the purse the full rounded
personality of what this individual is
like within moments of meeting them
and i thought that's what they brought
here with
um the the bard character uh the guy
playing guitar and then uh the goat man
character too kind of felt like that all
around with everyone even right down to
the the magic teacher lady to tessaia
to cecil
to saya i'm pretty sure to say or to
saya and it was neat the way they i
thought they handled her because it
starts off where she you just think
she's a threat especially upon the
introduction when she meets israel
through the portal realm and you're like
she's come for you so it just seems like
she's nothing but oh evil witch lady
and then she you see as she's actually
like training and slowly revealing more
of the sympathetic side to it and and
kind of having this uh provocation
nature towards uh yennefer with calling
her piglet and kind of talking down to
her
as a way to get a specific rise out of
her for a lesson
and then earning her way into being you
know just calling her by her actual name
towards the end it all felt very
purposeful and i really did find myself
like really rooting for yennefer uh
throughout this whole episode and i was
i was very emotionally gripped by
everything that was actually she kept
bringing me to tears like the first half
of this [ __ ] episode i just couldn't
stop uh and uh i loved her performance
and i'm remembering now actually that a
while ago we watched a v i watched a
video with ashley edner about um
it's on this channel uh about makeup
effects
and how she was this actress i remember
learning that she was very much
uh i think she developed some form of
scoliosis uh because she was in that
makeup but she had to be in that that
twisted nature position
for so long
and you could feel but that's what i
mean it's like it it sucks because she
does a great job
and but to know that she had like real
physical repercussions due to it is so
unfortunate
um but damn she gave a great performance
oh yeah so believable yeah
and even with this siri like the the the
way
the the veil is solely being stripped
down for her you know born a princess
and and then
uh you know from the from the from the
perspective from the first episode it
would look like her mom in the kingdom
was just so adored and and then being
thrusted into the the mud the dirt and
then the survivors of her what is that
kingdom called
something with a c
something with a c no it's not like
cyrillia but
uh not citadel it's stupid but yeah i
forget what it's called
uh but learning like oh damn everyone
thinks my mom's a [ __ ] you know but he
does not love the queen yeah having to
have that wake-up call and uh i like the
nuance of layers over that lady who took
her in but was
such a dick to the
little man and how he turns on her later
and just stabs her it's so it's so bleak
and and you could
you could feel them like the the
mournful sorrow just just in the air
yeah throughout this especially when
you're in the syria uh siri storyline
you can feel the overlapping of
circumstances and and classes and all
sorts of things that factor into a you
know somewhat medieval feeling world i
thought that with a lot of the way the
landscapes were captured i haven't
played witcher i've only seen like
trailers of the games i know it's based
on a book uh but in terms of video games
i've only seen like trailers of the
games and and and i've seen some people
play the game but i've never actually
myself dived into a video game
for it but i did find myself going this
looks like a video game brought to life
like certain certain shots when he's
like with the bard or just walking
through the town and stuff that i i
thought that was just really cool to go
like this looks like one of those open
world traveling fantasy games you know
well now we're in a cave and we're
learning magic
press a and b to catch that lightning
right and i like that juxtaposition too
of this episode you learn a lot about
magic and they and the way they
structure that of your coming in
understanding the idea of chaos how we
view magic as like the sculpting and
directing of that chaos yeah and yeah
you have this sort of like new world and
we're getting jumped in and yes like the
headmistress is very harsh on you know
our character who we're learning all
this through
and then later the episode you find out
like oh wow this is also all like stolen
and appropriated from the elves and like
to get
both of those levels of context like at
the opposite ends of the same episode i
thought was kind of fascinating and it
made it
feel a bit more historical or something
i don't know if that's quite the word
but yeah it gave it sort of a life that
i thought was interesting i'm not sure
where what the direction of the show is
going
like i don't know what the i know it's
like we got to have siri and geralt meet
up
but it's like they introduced a whole
bunch of other world-building plot
mechanisms in the prior episode that i
thought were going to be the main thing
like with that woman that he encountered
and the whole story about who she is and
how she has to be killed and all that i
thought that was going to be the through
line and maybe it's going to come back
but now we're introducing magic chaos
the witches the freaking elves like
there's so much they're introducing now
see now it feels to me like if it feels
like it'll be a while before a
full
through line reveals itself because i
almost feel like we're back to we saw
the fall of the empire in the last
episode and now we're sort of watching
as all the different pieces gather on
the board almost but i think there is
i'm confident though that there is a
direction
and i'm not
sitting here going like this show is
just meandering and going about no no
like you get the sense like i know it's
building somewhere i just don't know
where that's what it's building too it's
just not the linear plot right now true
true and uh
and i thought the easter egg guy was was
great too like i loved it i really
believed him as is really sincere i
didn't think he had an agenda
when that reveal comes around it does
hurt a lot and and i i thought like they
had really believable chemistry together
too
you know didn't feel forced like of
course handsome guy gonna be in love
with the girl who's got some like bottle
and body disformities that she has to
suffer with right now uh i i thought
that i thought that was really good i
really liked this one a lot and um i was
very much pulled in i i i was
i was i thought it was very effective i
decided to spend more time in this world
anyway gents and ladies what did you
think about this episode leave your
thoughts down below there's gonna be a
time we have to do a couple of these a
week
and uh i'm glad we're glad we're in that
position subscribe hit that bell hit
that like button last but not least
let's do a
maria hammond i've chosen you today
because if anybody would be the leader
of some kind of you know school of magic
and chaos sculpting
laying down the lawn building the future
generation fortifying them for battle
for
servitude even for advising of others in
power i think you would make a great
grand high witch lady i need to learn
her title in the actual show but it
doesn't matter you would have us
catching lightning into bottles you
would have us seeing through each
other's eyes to what be lies beyond
and uh you would also give us a cool
nickname that goads us into making some
kind of character breakthrough because
hey it seems like you have a lot of
people in your life to keep track of and
wrangle and whatnot and you could put
those skills to work
in a magical context because you are a
magical lady filled with generosity and
uh
generosity
because you're here
but uh
maria
you're great and we love you be well
shout out completed
okay
[Music]
you